[Music]
today Clark County School District
students are back in class and those
over at Southeast Career Tech are also
back in the kitchen it has its own
Whitney Restaurant which gives teenagers
a taste of The Culinary World Candace
Charles looks at the program
sector is dishing out a chance for local
teens to enter one of the silver State's
largest workforces the food service
industry anything else with that of the
nearly 2 100 students that attend SEPTA
about 150 are in the culinary program
I'd like to work in like a casino in the
restaurant and I feel like this is just
such a good Gateway while senior
Isabella Stover connects with patrons
Arisa green is catering to her skills
and confidence in the school's
industrial kitchen their High School
class is very realistic we run five
hours a day they're on their feet
they're not sitting down I learned all
the things that I wanted to learn secta
is one of seven career and Tech
academies in CCSD students must apply to
get in but it's competitive for a reason
culinary instructor Emily giacona says
she has casinos and hotels from across
the valley calling about her students
they want to NAB them now while they're
young as for the food it's delicious
it's really fantastic it's restaurant
quality the menu changes every two weeks
and none of the items are more than ten
dollars it's affordable for any student
giving students and staff an experience
to look forward to and culinary students
a taste of real life experience that can
be used in any industry if I applied for
a job I think I'd be pretty confident
objectives accepting applications for
the 23-24 school year until January 10th
we have those details on our website
8newsnow.com for now from the studio I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now